another question is how do I intend to
educate people on their environmental
issues it is necessary that you know
from the spiritual and religious point
of view as well and the social point of
view when education is essential to
protect the environment to protect the
line from harmful chemicals you know
there's a lot of chemicals and
fertilizers which are banned in the
Western countries are being stoutly the
donor countries and people don't even
know what they are using and how harmful
they are we need to educate people about
the after effects of pesticides and
chemicals and save the land and the
water now also educating people have
when they use soap and detergent another
cleaning agents make sure that they are
environmentally friendly so that doesn't
spoil the water recedes a big water
scarcity today and we need rotted to
sufficiently saving the bottom and then
the third thing is it's plantation I
would increase people to go out and
daughters to plantation plant trees eyes
much as they can and grow some food at
home and everyone can keep a part of mud
at home and start showing some lines and
some some tree says there's small shirts
and hums vegetable so distant so these
are the smell things that we need to
brainstorm awareness and the society and
all of us will have to pitch in and all
of a sudden take responsibility to make
drawing more greener and more safer
black spider